[Music]
i heard someone talking not too long ago
and they said something along the lines
of
well if you look at the
fact that we have cannabinoid receptors
in our brain
why else would we have those if it
weren't
for the fact that we were designed to
consume cannabis you know something
along those lines i think the logic was
was something like that
how how would you explain
the
uh the prevalence or existence of
receptors for these various types of of
of molecules i mean we could use
is it cannabinoids is that how you say
that correctly yeah i'm sure if i'm
pronouncing it correctly
what would your response to that be or
if you were sitting at a dinner table
and someone brought that up
where would you take it
i think it's not that complicated
actually the fact is
so we have cannabinoid receptors in our
brains
and uh
we have we actually have cannabinoids in
our brains we have these these peptides
called or these these prostaglandin-like
compounds called anandamines
and other types of things these are
effectively their our brain's own
cannabinoids
similarly you see this with opiates
opiate receptors in our brain bind to
these opiate peptides like endorphin and
dinorphin and right and those sorts of
things
and they just happen to bind to
the alkaloids from opium and have that
effect similarly with serotonin
receptors or dopamine receptors all of
these have their own endogenous the term
is in endogenous ligands and
obviously for serotonin receptors their
serotonin is the endogenous ligand
but interesting new findings tim show
there's formally there was a lot of
there was excitement there still is
excitement about endogenous dmt
you know and it's all related to the
pineal gland and that sort of thing
not so much the current understanding is
that the pineal is not so important but
dmt occurs in the brain in certain parts
of the brain
in rather high amounts in the frontal
cortex and this hasn't really been
discussed or studied as much as it
should my friend john chavez has gotten
into this in
it rather deeply
so dmt is an endogenous ligand and dmt
is a very simple molecule it's only two
steps from tryptophan which isn't
everything which is one reason why you
find dmt and
plants animals fungi
you know i sometimes in my lecture say
nature is drenched in dmt
it's not uncommon at all
oh how did this come about well it came
about because these
neurotransmitter-like compounds
found in the brain are also found in
plants and fungi and they have similar
evolutionary origins basically at some
point
the fungi the animals and the plants uh
split off from each other there's this
concept of the luca you know the
last universal
common ancestor which was
nobody knows what it was but we know
that it had to have existed
and probably probably it already had
the the genetic machinery to make these
neurotransmitter like compounds and and
just like neurotransmitters in the brain
what they do is they facilitate
signaling their signal transduction
molecules right
but plants and fungi and everything else
use very similar molecules
sometimes the same molecules
for signal transduction
processes
in the ecosystem
plants modulate their relationship with
other organisms in the environment
through signal transduction and these
messenger molecules
the the plants make the
these sort of
they're called secondary compounds
and that
implies they're not important they're
absolutely important but what they do
plants substitute biosynthesis for
behavior
right plants
modulate optimize their relationship
with everything in the environment
because they can't respond they can't
run away right they're stuck in one
place so they do it through chemistry
and sometimes you know this is like my
usual rap but sometimes the message is
very simple stay away get away from me
i'm poisonous you don't want to muck
with me you know other times the message
is come closer let's symbiose let's form
relationships
all of this is mediated by these signal
transduction processes which is a
which is a special kind of of signal
signaling process in organisms that
involves
a receptor and a molecule that comes
from
somewhere outside or some other part of
the brain and actually binds into that
receptor so it's a
physical molecular interaction that's
what i mean by signal transduction
as opposed to say nervous electrical
nervous transmission which also takes
place
that's the myst it's not really a
mystery it's uh
we evolved from the same origins
not surprising that our brains have
neurotransmitter-like compounds that
resemble those we find in nature and the
interesting thing is something like
psilocybin is a good example psilocybin
has
you know phylogenetically we're pretty
sure that psilocybin has been around for
at least 75 million years
the higher mushrooms the basidiomycetes
are very old long before there were
animal nervous systems for them to
interact with
but then animals did evolve and they
turns out they have interesting
effects with psilocybin what was
psilocybin doing
in nature before then well probably
insects it had to do with insects it was
either an attractant or repellent
more likely an attractive
you